we're good okay
Oh baby
yeah what's up a Jessica how you doing
bro yo what's up Viper gross I'm doing
well man which is playing some modern
warfare for the bleacher report offices
I'm just gonna change my brightness and
make this brighter because I'm playing
on like I want to say this like a
50-inch TV right now what's up yo what's
up back here how you doing man
I'm playing like a 50-inch TV right now
guys and everything looks really dark
and it's a little bit hard to like move
around but we're gonna make it work what
about sports treatment 20 I've honestly
I've never played FIFA in my entire life
I've only played call of duty I've been
playing call of duty since I was like 12
years old what's up Geoffrey how you
doing what's up Jersey how you guys
doing shout out to New Zealand Big Dawg
a my guy what's up bro
you know what tom is in New Zealand
right now man
oh my goodness
yeah what's up Ivan Garcia how's the new
team looking good man we've been
practicing yesterday and today and a few
days before we're looking really good
the league's gonna start in like another
six weeks so we got plenty of time to
practice before obviously we go to the
league and we like play in Minnesota but
we look good and they're also gonna
change a lot about this game too so
we're expecting a lot to change like the
spawns need to be changing they're gonna
be adding more stuff so it's gonna be a
lot better yeah thanks man you gonna
stop it next to me if you want this fun
I'm a good allottee or have you been man
I'm just trying to get like warmed up in
these pubs right now I'm gonna try to
drop a nuke on this TV that's gonna be
my challenge guys I was trying to do it
last night when I was at home playing
but it's really difficult watching from
work to pass the time that's what's up
man
off Renetta I left face broken help me
hit 200 please when I go what do you
mean Viper 200 what what do you need bro
oh my goodness I think they're all gonna
be right over there
[Applause]
yeah I think the game is worth buying
bro and they're especially like captain
to make these changes it's so hard to
shoot on this this TV it's our just
describe your suit if you want to get
200 subscribers describe for a minute
like everybody starts from zero man you
know like everyone has to start from
absolutely nothing so if you really want
something life just work for it make it
have to do you know oh my god I'm gonna
get smoked with these shotguns dude it's
really hard to make this work
[Applause]
I can't hit this guy from
I gotta flank it I'll I got two seconds
hopefully they challenge this I do like
pump so far honestly Geoffrey it's a lot
better I think this is the camera I'm
looking at or is it this one is it this
one of you
I think pubs are a lot better from what
they were in like the first few days of
the game um I think players are getting
more used to the game now so it's
getting better but like I said I think
it's been a word I think they're gonna
add the rent after public matches for
make the game a lot better and just
learning the maps which have not that
much flow to them at all honestly makes
the game a lot easier when she learned
them so because I've been playing the
game a lot and popping a lot I've been
enjoying it more the only thing I really
complain about I wish I had better
prestige emblems in the game because
those guys are like level 100 right now
and none of them have prestige or like
how many prestigious at all which is
kind of strange to me so I think if they
could add that it would be great because
the guns are fun to use and the camels
are pretty cool the only thing it's
really missing is prestigious and I
really want to try to get a new too it's
really hard it's Tim a lot of competive
definitely not no no how you doing
sensor - middlee I'm a pro contracted
Morrell stars player mobile game yeah
that's what's up man I'm 5 foot 11 Joey
I need salsa 48 appetito yeah I'll get
this is enough dope man
Braille Stars favorite brother I don't
know anything about Braille stars man
you guys can talk about that however you
guys want to in this yet
are you lebron Finn number one the brown
pen dude Bleacher Report just have me do
a thing with $15 they wanted me to build
like my best NBA team that I could make
and they had like $5 players $4 player
sweetie I'll play his first one put five
on the Bron either got any foul on
LeBron I need five on Shaq dad Yanis has
a $1 Yana says a $1 I took that easy
easy
I think they're gonna like post to quit
later on their socials like showing what
we were doing good so yeah I think
that's really cool which reports dope
too by the way guys I mean I've never
been here before this is my first time
I'm from Long Island I'm from New York
just like yo the kagra 5 is like yeah
this and that plug wheat reporters dope
man like I've been involved with sports
my whole life without playing them or
watching them and these guys are like
the Kings are just covering sports and
like sports
you know influencing and stuff so I
really love what they do man and I
really love bleacher report and and
being able to come to these offices
these guys is really cool because they
got it they got their shakedown man they
got it a really nice office what do you
want me to say talk about what a nuke ok
all right so we're gonna try to drop her
new today this is gonna be almost
impossible because we're playing on like
a 50-inch TV with leg input without
using our scuf controller but if we drop
her new today and I'll be insane that
would literally be insane if it happens
I don't know what I'll do I might have
to drop the control and just walk out if
that happens what's your new team are
not really caught member in your face
but I guess you left yeah so I wanted to
play Call of Duty for faze clan but they
never I guess would let me so I told him
like listen man I really want to play so
I'm gonna I'm gonna go join New York
because they really you know they value
me and they want me there they said I
will vest the luck and do what you got
to do so that's that's what I did I just
joined New York we announced the team I
think a couple of weeks ago now and
we're gonna be traveling to Minnesota
for the opener and I don't mean just
ours there's a guy right here - I know I
was like in here isn't he get us win and
I'll you know instead I'll give you some
homemade tamales for Christmas I got she
wrote
I don't even know you can get up gig oh
yeah like I said though if I drop a nuke
though this would be insane because we
have a lot of leg input and we're
playing on a huge Street and we don't
have an actual controller like we're
just like regular default ones so it'll
be a lot harder and like how fast is
this like time to kill and everything
like to look that can't really almost
got me by like just breathing I mean the
time to kill this game is so fast so
it's hard enough to drop a nuke like
with all the right stuff like having a
good monitor and all the good settings
but this shot right here I almost died
and I feel like I would have liked that
in a bit oh please don't come this way
you know yo you only want to answer
questions respect I think that's an
important thing with streaming man
especially especially if I'm gonna go in
someone else's stream like well I'm
Bleacher Report's you trip down right
now I'm gonna be on someone else's
stream I want to make damn sure
whoever's in the chat that's talkin
feels like they're a part of it man I
think that's like the number one thing
with being a streamer in general I don't
really get involved with streaming until
February this year but from what I've
learned
I feel like interacting with the chat is
key like you want to make people who are
watching you feel like they're a part of
everything you know like if you ignore
your viewers in your chat I don't really
see a point in streaming to be honest
I'm just gonna camp here don't see
somebody I know they're like right over
here guys watch it I'm gonna sprint out
watch me get you on my side
I was spawning out now all right they're
all gonna be back here still in
we're doing are we doing I got a premium
so heavy because me baby what is that
what are you throwing at me man
[Applause]
what are you doing no put that flank
I'll keep coming to your post but thanks
guys my whole team is just sitting here
though y'all see this they're all just
sitting in this little room right here
come on guys let's move out
let's get involved in some action Jesus
this leg oh my god I love streams clean
track guy agree who's the girl - brother
MJ yo 100% LeBron James dude 100%
I know MJ he's got all those accolades
right he's got the six titles the six
MVPs I get it I get it
maybe I'm biased because I grew up
watching LeBron but LeBron is might do
man and plus I went to the finals when
they lost to the Warriors I think two
years ago I went to the old life two
years ago I went to the finals and three
years ago I went to the finals and two
years ago when I went to the finals it
was game for the Warriors up 300 work
300 and I met LeBron James's kid brownie
after the game and he came up to me as I
go says here he's like yo face and she
watched your videos and I was trying so
hard not to fanboy I was like yeah hey
what's your name dude it's like I'm
brawny you know Brown James jr. eyes
like oh yeah yeah of course maybe so I
start to play it cool but I damn well
who he was man I think what's up dude I
made shirts for the picture and
everything that was dope what excites
you did with the franchise everything
man like I'm a big NFL guy too so I love
like the NFL schedule like the weekly
game format this
and that's exactly alcoholic if he's
doing it for franchising so like every
week we're gonna be traveling to a new
place playing a new new team starting
January 25th so you know being able to
travel to like London and then the next
week going to Paris to play call of duty
is like a dream like how is that a
reality like I'm just gonna take it
accept it and just do the best that kind
of be the best I could be you know and
I'm really excited for the league to
start everything they kicked off because
it's literally a dream and like to play
video games for a living is a dream and
I don't take that for granted you doing
no not November nah man what's your
favorite team whatever team LeBron play
is for us so obviously the Lakers right
now and they got a D and my girlfriend's
a big Kauai dancer she's a Clippers fan
so we got like a fun little rivalry
right there she loves quiet I like quiet
ooh he's dope but I got it I'm always
Lord of abroad man I'm a loyal guy so
whether LeBron decided to follow
[Applause]
you fix a lot how do you fix lag with a
50% GB my Internet's perfect you can't
bro like I'm doing it right now as you
guys can watch the gameplay like I'm on
a 50-inch TV and you just can't fix it
it's just the recommended thing like
every pro player anyone that plays the
game professionally or even
competitively plays on a 23 inch monitor
so if you guys are interested in being a
Call of Duty pro player or a console FPS
player even fortnight - I don't know
what the PC guy sees I think these are
27 three fortnight but if you're a gamer
for Call of Duty if you want to be the
best player you could be if you want to
like have a good KD and drop nukes and
you know just be a really good player
playing a 23 inch monitor it'll be the
best chance you have it like being a
good player that's unfortunately just
pop they're coming from brothers like
that shot right there I would have
definitely
[Applause]
you're dead and then this guy appeals
stop there we go good eight bullets
okay nice could kill you kill flash UAV
standing by there we go oh we streaking
we streaking
oh we got the century let's go pop that
BAM never load this thing real quick get
another kill at the century all right is
this right here in OGG I might need to
take this for the mp5 I don't know where
they're spawning out either I think
they're gonna be back left they got to
be back left hold on guys I'm going off
right now on this monitor
come here papa don't don't you be doing
this
don't you be yo boy
okay come on let's go Kill Confirmed
I'll take it dude I'll take it dude
10 kills streak to end the game let's go
all the maps are bad stop blinding
yourself I'm not lying to myself playboy
I agree with you i think these maps are
horrible I've been playing Call of Duty
since I was 12 years old man and I can
honestly say I probably played as much
Call of Duty as anyone on this planet
and these are definitely the worst maps
call of duty as and I know they're gonna
fix it I know they're adding new maps so
I'm not really too worried about it I'm
just honest and as a competitive player
a lot of the maps that I'm playing right
now are gonna be massively playing in
the league so like there's nothing we
could really do about it we have to play
what we got and I'm just grateful to
even be in the Call of Duty League and
to be playing this game for a job I mean
you know I just try to think of it like
that man so I got to learn these maps
whether I like them or not so I'm just
gonna have to play it what's up okay
okay
preach bro thank you yeah I got you man
how you're in Maryland y'all kill the
Halloween costumes yeah thanks King
Warren yeah we're doing well man so the
reason I'm here right now for the most
part guys obviously like we all wanted
to meet each other in person cuz I've
been talking to bleacher report for a
couple of months now we filmed a show
together it's called battle stations and
we're really excited about it I haven't
seen the whole show yet I only literally
saw the three first minutes of the show
with the executive producer because we
had to go straight a hair and makeup
ready to take some head shots we had to
record like a little like bleacher
report Twitter video I think it's gonna
be so we're doing all that but the
reason I'm here right now is because of
the show that we film is called battle
stations it's kind of like it's kind of
like an MTV Cribs type show where we go
into the athletes house we check out
their house we check out their gaming
stations how they like the game the type
of nutrition they like to put in their
body and just kind of like humanizing an
athlete to an extent because all these
athletes are always put on the pedestal
and at the end of the day I mean yeah
they they're living crazy dream lives
but they're humans too just like anyone
else and I think that's what the show
does best is like capture these people
as natural you know
in their natural elements and I showing
that - just like gods like for example
the first person we filmed was deer and
Fox and he's literally enemy at the
center he's literally just like me I
mean he he works out every day he plays
basketball and then he plays ecology
like he was prestige master in black ops
forth you know so it really captures
that well and I knew like building it
that it was gonna be really good and
after watching the first three minutes
it's literally exactly what I expected
it to be it's a really fast-paced it's
really fun to watch I think all types of
people would enjoy the show and it's I
think the person of us come out on
Thursday right
Thursday's gonna be the first episode so
you guys can check it out on Bleacher
Report I'm Paulina be posting clips of
it to and we're just really excited
about it we really hope that you guys
like it because we put a lot of time
into the show and we think it came out
really really great so I hope you guys
like it too when it comes out
had to get Jews you're intolerant three
times in the show I agree
I don't know karl-anthony towns do
here's my boy though so I would love to
get you she's like right there because
of the like input I just look like an
idiot
juju is my boy I'd love to get him on I
don't know Carl Anthony towns though but
I'm sure like if the show gets picked up
and it goes the series will be getting a
lot of athletes on the show primarily
gamers but we'll be getting all kinds of
athletes too I'm sure
and we're just gonna try to help with it
like the whole point is just to show
these athletes in the natural elements
and they're just like wow nice shoes
yeah you see this guy's look at this man
look at this guy right here dude come on
man dude your table you kill got to be
on there for sure much respect man that
you played with buddy what come to the
best suits for Team Deathmatch I would
take down this mp5 right here screenshot
this this is the class I used and these
are the attachments I used on the mp5 I
highly recommend this class like imma
put on a show for you right here ready
check this out look how fast you kill
with this gun dude
they got that killed but anymore guys
right in front me right here I think
BAM dead it's gonna be more right here
they're all gonna come right here BAM
dead chief flash they're still gonna
come from right here I can see their
grenades there's gonna be more right
there come on keep em comin sweet
finally I never used to scar before that
mags a shot what do you think about your
[ __ ] team this year Brandon I think we
have one of the best teams in the league
I mean we have the second oldest team so
we're all the really experienced and
that's something I like because a lot of
the cop players are younger I mean I
think they're all the agents but a lot
of the the top player I know there's a
good variety of like top players that
are older top players that are like 19
and 20 I prefer to be around older
players because I am 25 I don't want to
be around like you know really immature
young 18 year old kids especially
there's like a group identification you
know it's just not a good dynamic I
think so we have an older more
experienced team that has champions I
think I'm gonna be pieces we have we
have treasures than MVP we have attaches
a world champion we have accuracy who
won like three majors in World War two
accuracy one of them maybe two as well
yeah we got a lot of really good talent
on the team and a lot of like very
motivated hungry guys to win as well I
haven't I don't know about all of you
but this con when I play it I have fun
haven't had that since black ops 2 I
honestly dude this game is growing on me
every single day like in the beginning I
thought the maps were trash and I still
think they are but the actual like
gunplay and how you shoot is
for me once they had red dots these pubs
I think he'll make the game a lot better
though
Dougie fresh was good eat then how you
doing man or Evan I'm sorry about you
know the best Street guy had so far by
the way was the the best streak I had so
far is that century gonna play from the
last game I think I won like a 10 Street
to end it I finished y'all I'm def gonna
be following you for the season so
they're watching Pro Cod to say let's go
man what's he play for I so say that
fake for New York so we play for the sub
liners we just announced the team
branding like two weeks ago so if you
guys aren't familiar with like Call of
Duty and franchise and how it all works
basically each team had to pay 25
million dollars to get into the
franchise like to get a lead spot right
because they're spoke spots in the
league and obviously like so hard over
here that's crazy
so there's 12 league teams right there's
Paris Minnesota London Toronto New York
- in LA one in Florida one in Seattle
one in Texas and there's 12 spots it's
25 million dollars per spot and
basically it's like it's kind of like
NFL like it's like City based
franchising and we all play from January
to August like the the final will be in
August and yeah it's like a week-to-week
league like every single weekend we're
gonna be traveling to a new home team
wherever it is like the first ones in
Minnesota on the 25th of January so
we're gonna be going to Minnesota
playing into them and then we're gonna
be flying to London playing it's London
when we fly into I think LA and playing
LA and then we go to Paris or we go to
London in Paris so like because I
represented New York and I live in New
York I don't have to move but all these
other players who don't live in the
state that they're playing in they have
to move over to that place so it's
literally like the best way I can
describe it it's just like NFL or even
like NBA but it's not 82 games it's 20
so there's a lot of similarities between
it's gonna be fun like this is year one
like all this stuff just got announced
in the past three weeks and we're at the
forefront of it so my team is New York
so the New York subway owners NYS L for
short and this is the very beginning I
mean it's only getting a bigger every
single year from here and I'm just
really happy because I've been involved
in competitive Call of Duty since 2011
and you know now it's 2019 that we have
franchising and this guys in the same
corner that he got me in last time look
at this man look at this woman mrs.
quieter what are you doing you drank a
hundred and fifteen you want played a
more modern warfare than anyone in this
game and you were sitting in quarters
you are sitting in corners I don't
understand I can't wait until modern
warfare changes this they've already
said they're gonna patch I can't wait
until we pass San Pedro
yeah the matchup in LA I don't think the
schedules been announced yet so I don't
know if I'm allowed to talk about it but
uh yeah we're gonna be going to every
single City between those months so it's
gonna be really exciting for sure
yeah I don't know where to go I don't
know where people are there's one
goodbye
let me heal up real quick what are you
is really extreme I use this team on
twitch but bleat trip board shoots on
YouTube so they have me here today they
want to be the stream so here I am
Oh y'all stream on Twitch - oh yeah the
stream on Twitch - guys this stream on
twitch and YouTube they wanted me to
stream on YouTube for them there so
we're streaming on youtube today
yeah a lot people know in the spawn
points yeah it's not about like knowing
the spawn points really it's more so
about just getting the mini-map where
like when people shoot you could see him
on it you know I think that's such a big
thing that whole movie this baby is
sitting all the way in the build in a
Zach wait is this kid still in this
corner right here I will lose my mind if
usually I would lose my mind if he's
right okay bags I was ready to snap if
you were still sitting there after all
that time goodbye
oh no he's on the stairs
I hate us through the chat but y'all
watching for tips yeah if you guys have
any questions for me about the game or
about the show I mean ask me away man
anything about battle stations anything
about sports dude anything about call of
duty franchising asked me away because
there's still a lot of details about
franchising that still haven't been
announced like I literally was talking
to New York today about some certain
things about franchising we still don't
know because it's so new so like we're
all trying to figure it out at the same
time so any questions you guys have
about sports or about battle stations or
why I'm here right now just asked me the
chat I'll answer it oh my goodness bro I
think they're all just literally gonna
spawn right here I kind of want to end
this game because he's got to play it's
so hard to this I'll be streaming later
today guys - by the way on my on my
twitch channel twitch.tv slash sensor
obviously when I get home I'm gonna go
straight from here I think we should
report so nights man they got me a
really nice car they got the guy waiting
outside literally sitting there which is
awesome so the second I end this stream
I'm going home and and my booty is
getting parked in my station and I'm
streaming and I'm making a video trying
to get a dude because it's really hard
and I really want to try to get a
nucleant screen doesn't get 30 straight
kills with just your gun and the way
this game is right now it's just really
difficult so if I could get one that'd
be great content on YouTube
I really want to get that just freaking
shocked look at this look at this I'm
gonna use this shotgun next game I'm
gonna use the shotgun guys you know
typical game yeah I actually was just
talking the typical gamer on the car
ride over here cuz I was looking into
streaming on YouTube and he's I think
one of the biggest YouTube Jim he's just
like 9 million subscribers
he's been streaming that YouTube for
years now so he's giving me some advice
on that true
I hope your team plays Dallas I want you
to playing scream sticks again in the
finals listen I told him I was like
listen yo if we get crammed and we're
going to get something the grand finals
put me in man easy win dude we'll be
playing it's every single team in the
league though why does he play PC Habib
the the league is on PlayStation 4 it's
been on console ever since I can
remember so that's that's the way they
have it I'll set up alright so the
shotgun is the 725 I don't think I have
anything a lot for it but honestly you
probably don't even need it because how
good this thing is alright so we're
gonna use yo D obviously ghost and then
battle-hardened it's like you kind of
need to use these in pubs those like the
the perks I think are very necessary
people are gonna get so mad when I use
this thing their shotgun is so lame love
this thanks Karen what am I using to
heal myself Josh Ramona's just perk
right here so if you look on your edit
loadouts if you go to tactical there's a
thing called stim it's really good I
recommend using it in pubs it's not a
lot of competitive but for pubs it's
good
Bleacher point as gaming play pub geez
next I've never played pub G I'm a Call
of Duty pro so I'm playing call of duty
love this thanks Karen will it be
Rajkumar's be like in sports as a
transfer engine yes there will be a lot
of trades I'm sure there'll be a lot of
trades this year because a lot of these
teams are just kind of like put together
based on last year and this game plays a
lot different from last year's games so
I'm assuming a lot of them are gonna be
traded
you got Shou got three nukes in 17
minutes I'm not sure about that it's
really freaking hard to get a nuke you
can't get three nukes once you get one
new the game ends Kotzur xi these days
you know flex yep you've been looking at
social media grow anything with Call of
Duty is bumping
anything with modern warfare is bump it
bro like it is people posting clips I've
seen like multiple clips with millions
of views on mana warfare I haven't seen
that for a lot of Call of Duty's in the
past so I think this game actually has a
lot of hype and like if it didn't I
would say like I always say what I mean
that I mean what I say and I think this
game is gonna be a really good polish
game with all comes out sensors girl I
love you thanks man I've never used this
shotgun before but I've just so bad for
these people go oh my god what is this
thing bro see right there damn it
Lakers or Clippers definitely Lakers
Clippers are nice though um but I just
think when it goes to the playoffs what
do you have LeBron an ad in the playoffs
I can't imagine them using honestly like
I really just can't clippers are gonna
be a really good team though it would be
great to the Clippers and Lakers in the
Western finals this year that's probably
what's gonna happen right how did we
think about it logically I don't know if
I want to keep using as reference
sensitive and a trade to Seattle for a
twisty Seattle's has a really good team
too I love those guys over there I know
the guy who owns it Steve's a good dude
we play blackjack one time in Cali
he's a good dude after these on that
team is my favorite guy I've ever seen
with I mean I wouldn't be here today
without apathy he I mean I like limited
in our tradition get it dry I really
like got to do a lot I would always
never Brian
they got octane too so they they got a
really good squad but I'm not gonna be
in New York now I'm a proud New Yorker
and I love the team and I love the guys
I want to help build this you know this
is what I want to be a part
I might have to get rid of the shotgun
for this map this might not be the best
range let me switch the mp5 what is this
this is a call of duty modern warfare
I'm using this 75 shotgun which is like
they dig there see hopefully that's what
we lipnick's
I'm not really a big fan of either one
of them but because we got Kyrie and KD
on the Nets now a poly root for them but
I mean the Knicks I've been I'm gonna
live since 1994 and I can't remember the
only time the Knicks were decent was
when they went to the playoffs is the
2cw something and I'd like a really old
team of Tyson Chandler and haven't
really been good since then so I haven't
really had anything to report the mix in
my life I've always been a LeBron guy so
where am I getting hit them
[Applause]
[Applause]
nice rap there's a definite not win
again TJ Pascal that are gonna carry no
way there'll be a good seed but the
sixes are gonna beat them in the
playoffs for sure this section should
have beat him last year man if Jo
alibied wasn't hurt they would've
definitely won I think they're all
spawning the do be right here
[Applause]
goodbye let's go we're gonna head with
that slide ooh
the shotgun got me again thank hamster
stop using this gun it's not fair it's
not fair
my Pomeranian could use that gonna get a
kill on me dude they're all just sitting
in the back of this snipers and shotgun
snipers and shotgun snipers and shotguns
everywhere you go dude I'm headed with
the flank you still fans no drip you got
left I'm flying out bro goodbye
goodbye yeah that's what happens when
you can get shot in the back dude maybe
if you leaves around a little bit you
want to get shot they all just spawn
right there all of them just spawn right
there and I get obliterated by the
shotgun I don't play fantasy football at
all dude they're all just posting with a
shot ease up there man I had to play a
very patient here bro I'm on a jet ski
[Applause]
hi what's up Chris
Lakers 76ers in the finals yeah I think
that's very logical Lakers or Clippers
vs. Sixers is probably like the most
logical thing or the box to I mean you
can't sleep on them the Bucs and the
Sixers have really good tears that could
flank this kid real good
have you tried to shock them you see how
[Applause]
you're probably still sitting here right
[Applause]
yeah I could see where the sound should
go possible
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's Emmett's place kotte yeah I play
a player bed sometimes we used to play a
lot of MW remastered like right when he
was getting direct memory went bang got
rats it to the league and he like hurt
his foot when he was like rehabbing is
what we felt a lot of Ecology d together
Ben's my guy he's nasty I went to that
playoff game last year when he went out
Jared Dudley called him out and he just
dropped like 30 on him I was watching
that doesn't Burkle inside I went to
that was fun it's so hard to shoot okay
we're just gonna we're just gonna have
to constantly flank him I think that's
the best play
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my god the shotgun again this thing
is so crazy dude
i'ma try cob mobile poisonous no what's
the benefit of scuf controller in cod
everything bro I mean first of all you
could jump and shoot at the same time
you don't have to let go of your analog
stick that's number one they're smart
triggers you could aim in faster you
could jump faster you basically do
everything faster with scuf controller
like if you're if you're a competitive
player you have to use one highly
recommend it if you don't then you just
have a disadvantage and it's approved by
the league tier so everyone in the
league uses some form of one I think
there's only like maybe one two guys max
you don't use one so I highly recommend
it if you're trying to get into it if
you want to say 5% you can use code
sensor to save 5% on the stuff to
[Applause]
shotgun austenite the nice you should
switch off that mp5 news MP 77 I don't
have an unlock yet I think I'm like one
level away from the mocking it just play
cloth yeah you could play claw - but
claw is really just not something I've
done but some players like to play claw
it takes some time to get used to it I'm
just gonna to flank this every time I
think how does one join your team it's
all full
but basically if you're really good
they'll they'll pick you up it's kind of
like NFL like how would you join on the
Seahawks or like jets or the Giants I
mean to be honest with you man I feel
like anyone could join the Jets right
now like who is this guy right here this
Alan
yeah you could join the Jets man who
could probably get on the team yeah it's
it's you know I got a driving is he
gonna fit in and practice then that just
makes key excuse me do we have like a
protein bar or anything like that
oh thanks man
any type of like a like a birthday cake
or a chocolate I love birthday cake man
birthday cake is my favorite
[Applause]
[Applause]
what says if you use I use 5:5 but
because I'm playing on this monitor I
think I want four cool right now cuz I'm
on three three because it's like a huge
monitor honey hours do you put in a week
when you're prepping for a tournament
it's pretty rough man I mean I would say
I would say probably like eight hour ten
hour days every single day sometimes
twelve depending it's pretty intense
dude alright let's see something real
quick okay yeah I got some level fifty
once and one more level I can use the
mp7 keep blanking up yeah that's
definitely the play heat control yeah I
had to control for breakfast today I had
control I had a good shoulder workout
and then I just came straight to New
York City and I'm at the bleacher report
studios right now and a bunch of people
have been playing the lessee cutting it
back into it now I guess the same caller
didn't really change too much it's gotta
grind the game out every single year the
game's different so you just got to play
watching film helps a lot too young nah
I mean just like any other sport I think
if you watch film on other people and
see the way that they play in their
tendencies are like watching the best
players play and like copying some of
the things that they do and then heading
your twist onto it is really important
to you as David laid always man that's
my guy I haven't seen him actually saw
him in Houston less than a month ago do
you think all the dudes ass boy
absolutely definitely
what's the most exciting thing you've
done since planning about it every
probably when he liked my first
championship in 2011 the national
championship that was definitely the
moment in my life when I was young I was
17 and it told me like I could do
anything I set my mind to because I put
a lot of work into winning that man and
what's that one that I was like re and I
could do anything if I really like try
hard enough
[Applause]
until then I would use googled bro like
literally if you have any problems at
work guys just go to Google and ask
Google anything I mean you can find out
so much for information on there
but just getting it to a gym is
definitely the first step will you be
getting through a gym and you just start
going like that's the first step and
that's what I recommend there was - I
couldn't even see them all you the man
bro oh we got that quest bar nice
did you guys tag me in it right now
okay I'll know what my floor tile here
is I'm gonna retweet the same guy for a
second
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is [ __ ] for you we've got my
wavy beginning flyover well
[Applause]
my enemy at the gun shop
friendlies UAV online enemy
[Applause]
enemies you a most under a cot map in
your opinion on this game what do you
mean like an overall I don't know
underrated to be honest with you I
honestly think this map is really
underrated though romanza I think a lot
of the pros hate on this map right here
but I think it's one of the best ones
I've really enjoyed this did you all
hear that my teammates getting heated no
he's getting so mad I think they're like
just sitting in here at the shotgun look
at him oh my God he's got destroyed do
you play for tonight I used to I used to
play for night a little bit when I first
came out but I don't play it anymore no
he got me my back never heard of you
till now but it's been fun watching you
journey you're damn gonna muscle every
metaphor dude thanks young knight
honestly bro it's really hard to play on
a 50-inch TV but if y'all want to watch
me later tonight on twitch twitch TV
slash censor I'll be streaming on there
on my own setup and it'll be a lot
easier to just like I guess play
enemy at the barbershop this year's game
check he be called ADA Bob yes it does I
would say so I mean the game has so much
potential I think this game seriously
have a lot of potential and I hope that
oh my goodness the same thing happy
together they're all just sitting there
yeah gosh Davis trip Bayless yeah you
can make this up dude I got the bleacher
report offices playin modern warfare and
we got a guy in the name the guy in the
game referencing undisputed and my boy
I love Shannon Sharpe and it's gonna be
a list I watched him every single day
literally every single day I love Skip
Bayless man he's like a walking beam
dude and he's been posting on a drip
blade Bayless content recently so to see
another guy in the game like named Rick
Bayless is really funny oh babe get the
century Bowl I got it two games to go on
gunrunner I'm gonna try to get it here
too it's just like I said it's just
really difficult I'm 11 it's six
surprising I don't know how 11 or six
right back but they're all just running
back here too we gotta hit this flank
mass they're spawning out again we got a
foot to the other side of the map maybe
I could beat this kid in mid right here
he's gonna be on this little like sad
pit thing look at him
okay you just gave it up guys
this guy's gonna come about at midday
I'll come on we got that killer get that
killer the shotgun dude you can't trust
the shotgun guys so somebody uses a
shotgun they're not my friend dude I
prefer to watch first thing I like them
both I switch between both of them
I think first take does a really good
job of getting in like really fun people
to the show you know like obviously
there being any work and everything and
I like their set a lot but I think I
think both shows are really good they're
all I guarantee they're all sitting over
here again yeah
they all just right here again just
sitting
[Applause]
what here item well that's the guy just
showed up here
[Applause]
got flipping again
[Applause]
what's the barbershop where are they
yeah so first sensor that's dope yeah
yeah man my best kill streak so far is
like 19 oh I hate shotguns in this yeah
they're gonna be changing that they're
gonna get rid of these shotguns dude I
think like within a few days honestly
and that shotguns big they gotta do it I
agree good old Pete they gotta do
something that that Silas suit they got
to make a couple of really big changes
which they make um I think it would be
so much better he just dripped Bayless
just collateral us with a shotgun man
drip Bay let's make it plays out here
you see this guy black ops 1 remaster
would be great Habib Max Kellerman and
Steven a Smith that they're both good
high-low sensitive ear 6 definitely low
Aria highly recommend like a lower like
a anywhere between like I always have my
mic on Auggie oh this guy trip Bailey's
trying socks man yeah they're talking
smack you guys together I think I just
don't like the mp7 let me see maybe I
should I think I'll just use the mp7 for
a little bit just for fun did i unlock
it yet
I still have it 54 I thought it was 52
all right so we have some time to go
until 54 honestly wanted war remastered
I would be the happiest person on the
planet
try the Arden I'm gonna keep using mp5
for now cuz I have to keep trying to try
to get better with it because that's our
gonna be using competitively but yeah
just to reiterate guys I'm here in
Bleach report for like probably another
hour or so we did some headshots we we
met we had a little bit of meetings
because we're doing a lot of other stuff
we have a TV show that we filmed
together it's called battle stations
it's gonna be on bleacher report it's
Thursday so if you guys are interested
in watching it is this Thursday right
this Thursday episode one with the air
and Fox I'm so happy to be talking about
this man we put a lot of time into this
a lot of thought went into this a lot of
preparation went into this the shoots
themselves for like 12 hour days
it's a really good show I only was able
to watch the first three minutes because
we've been moving around so fast
everyone here at bleacher report is top
notch they're all really good at what
they do and they all move extremely fast
because we're all New Yorkers and that's
just the way we we get around so I'm
really impressed honestly by them
because I've never been here before and
like I came in went straight into a
meeting went to another meeting went
straight for photos were straight for
makeup went straight here there's Duncan
some basketballs
you know did like my little segment over
here on the side picking my favorite
basketball team we're straight to the
live stream so we're moving around
really fast and Episode one like I said
though with the air at Fox Thursday I
don't know what time but make sure you
guys follow bleach record on Twitter do
you know the time is gonna come out
10:00 a.m. Eastern 10 o'clock Eastern
guys on bleacher report make sure you
guys go support it and check it out
because if you guys support it there's a
good chance to get picked up and it'll
go to like another place I don't know
exactly where I don't I don't do it the
business stuff I let them take care of
it but the more support it gets the
better and this is a show I I really
believe in it man like I'm truly
believing it and I think it's gonna
resonate with you guys I don't think I
need to like like like beg for you guys
to watch or anything but I just really
hope you guys do because it's a really
good show and I hope that it gets picked
up for series I hope we could film with
more athletes if we can do more fun
things because this is like this for me
this is the types of things that I think
is gonna be happening in the world like
there's a lot of athletes out there
especially now everyone's younger right
and they've all been playing video games
the whole life like Call of Duty and I
guess not fortnight and video games are
a big part of people's lives man and
especially these athletes too and a lot
of people who watch sports also watch
gaming too and I just love this
collaboration and I really hope that
this show gets seen as as by as many
people as possible because
[Applause]
it's drip please the girl yeah I agree
man yo set Swiss up here my I'll watch
it yet let me don't you think I'll put
it on my socials bleach reporter post it
on theirs and just let me know what you
think man I'm 5 foot 11
table you car 5 foot like 10 and 3/4 I
would say my license expired 11 so I'll
just say 511 you know just guys shoot me
my back was good with you girl look at
him he's trying to pop you at the shotty
goodbye
nice shot dude you everything caught
World War one would be boring I don't
know like it depends on their focus up
get that new finally Tegan I'm gonna be
rude with you bro it's gonna be nearly
impossible man like to drop a nuke right
now but I'm gonna try against tonight I
really want to get a nuke and push some
on YouTube and my first 70 thanks Eddie
I'm gonna try to get a nuke later I'm
still gonna try here I'll try later to
you though but it's just really really
difficult playing on a 50-inch TV to get
a nuke cuz you got to be like playing
perfect and playing it's like really bad
players so but we're gonna shot man
nothing is impossible
Jesus big you ever now brown I'll be
I'll be she just if you get it
[Applause]
everyone's using the shotgun everyone's
using this thing right now oh dude I
think he's just sitting there with the
shotty I'm not going that way everyone
dude I'll get this thing go naturally
person that seems that kinda new can see
oh right I saw a Chuck get that nuke and
I was like yo I'm playing some
headquarters now too
I almost had it man how was that 19
kills in the game ended last night the
same maknae shot got a nuke on the only
thing about the mp5 I don't like is like
how slow it reloads that's the only
thing about it you're 511 you could dunk
that's mad bounce bro yeah I mean this
this hoop athletes report I think is
like a foot shorter because they were
telling me the story I think I think
Tobias Harris like broke the rim or
something when you came here that's what
I think that's what happened but I could
definitely dunk on this one I'm gonna do
it and like post on Instagram because I
think that's really cool content I'm
gonna post that and then I'm gonna go
home
I'm gonna try to get a nuke and I'm a
shot upload to YouTube
cause my starting on podcast or Escada
main focus for now I feel like I could
have a really good podcast man cuz I
feel like I could talk about a bunch of
different things and I have a lot of
different opinions on things too and I
can see a bunch of different sides in a
story so I think I would do really well
like hosting a podcast and I can title
it like uncensored right because my name
is censor but right now like my focus
just Call of Duty man I love this game I
love call of duty and I love sports so
uh and I'm so like my head's in a
million different places right now guys
like I got I got this TV show going on I
got my Call of Duty franchise
I got Jim shark G fuel I got really
exciting news of G fuel
life-changing news of gee feel I'm gonna
tell you guys about in like another week
from now which is just incredible but I
can't say it yet I have my youtube
channel my twitch livestream like I just
feel like my head's in so many different
places and it's really hard for me to
just focus so like if I was at a podcast
on top of that - I feel like I would
lose my mind like I just want to have
the time in the day to do everything I
need to get done my day has been great
so far though May I had a great workout
I did some head shots for G fuel and I
took a car to the city and I've been
with bleacher report for the other half
of the day and then I'm gonna go home
and play some more Call of Duty so it's
been a good day man I dominate you
everyone you let him peek I'll put
$10,000 on the fact that you want to
beat me - wanna be one I'll give you the
odds man I put 10,000 down you got to
put a thousand down so if you lose you
pay a thousand if I lose I'll pay you
ten grand bro that's how confident I am
that I beat you don't wanna be one do
they're just gonna come flying through
the store I could I'm gonna go around
this way they're gonna with the shotgun
looking it with the shotgun those giant
still come on Vinny just yeah i know i
think i think because daniel Jones is a
lot more dominated people are exposing
him now and he's also a rookie so he's
gonna make a lot of mistakes and have a
lot of turnovers right please don't yeah
but yeah he did not look that good last
night man but I do have faith in daniel
Jones I'm gonna do I think he's a great
player I really think he has a good
promising career so I think next year
when they rebuild they're gonna be a lot
better
enemy is a smokestack
how'd you manage to time to do these
things never girlfriend - you have a
girlfriend I have two dogs and I own a
house so like owning a house itself is a
lot of work there might be amount of
upkeep and cleaning and just paying
bills and stuff is a lot like it's like
a full-time thing and then having a
girlfriend obviously if you guys have a
girlfriend you know what it's like man
girlfriend wants to do something
girlfriend wants to go out somewhere you
know you got to go out to restaurants
and stuff you do things together so
there's a lot that goes into a man but
you know it's easy when you do the
things that you love everyday and I
could honestly say that I love what I do
so it doesn't feel like too much worth
to me and my girlfriend's super
supportive of me too so it makes it that
much better he heard me he turned around
look at him look at him oh my here hands
oh my god oh yay
not a giant something always rebuilding
it look big when I was in high school
doing two Super Bowls in like five years
men Giants are great
I've been 5000 I beat you tweet me on
Twitter right now let MP tweet me on
Twitter put your money where your mouth
is bro listen I'm converted my house a
natural guest right now it's gonna cost
me ten grand that's an easy it's like a
$5,000 down payment five thousand when
the jobs complete I will gladly take
your five thousand dollars you put that
towards that down payment and I won't be
one you at any time grow put your money
where your mouth is mad
I'm a flank it again hopefully I don't
think I pick it up we got him out good
there's ol collapse give me it yeah
let's go there's another one right here
- no the shotgun again this thing
doesn't take any still 49ers have a good
chance of winning the Superbowl I love a
Patriots 49ers Super Bowl I would love
time to go out on top - I'd love the
time to win another Super Bowl and just
go out on top
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah they did Renan I'll be right back
okay man right here my homies getting
somebody
that shotguns a problem bro thanks for
inspiring me to lift
yo of course Cody I got you man I'm over
the Bears not hitting the goalposts
bears need a new quarterback man I'm
just gonna sorry to break it to you man
yo homeboy missed your bisque you put up
nine yards in the first half nine yards
bro listen I've never been a quarterback
I can't throw a football but I could put
up nine yards man nine yards and I have
I'm best
I know these linemen a quick I know
these deeds are quick these 350-pound
guys are behemoths and they're quick but
they ain't outrunning me I'll run
outside of the pocket throw a little
dish pass who that guy they got a Cohen
to Rico in as their running back yeah
I'll run out of the pocket throw a
little pass to Cohen
give me five yards right there I can get
nine yards and a half dude
Mitch too risky nine yards in the head
I'm sorry for you man I'm sorry man
having a bad quarterback sucks I've seen
it I'm I'm a giant center chest fan
because of my dad my dad's a die-hard
Jets fan I grew up my stepdad he's a
Giants fan I grew up watching the Giants
win some more of a Giants fan but I've
seen the Jets and they've had horrible
quarterbacks man is it sucks when you
wake up every Sunday trying to watch
your team play and your quarterback
sucks so I feel for you man why set your
own bleep chump confused isos Tebow boos
reason I'm here right now is because
bleacher report and I filmed it show
together it's called battle stations
it's gonna be coming out thursday 10
a.m. on Bleacher Report's twitter you
guys can watch it the first episodes
with me in the air and Fox basically I
go to the air in Fox's house we check
out his gaming setup and we see more
about the lives about these athletes and
and the way that they live their lives
and we kind of like make them a little
bit more humanized because you know
these are kids making crazy amounts of
money like living a dream life and they
always get put on these pedestals and
people you know don't really know much
about them so the show really does a
great job of showing these people and
how they are as people and it's just
awesome so that's why I'm here right now
it'll be less rough though if you are
giving me 10 to 100 v1 what's up
censored live from Russia hey Chris
what's up dude what's up say I'm from
Detroit
welcome Kody guys I like face cuz I
wanted to play competitive Call of Duty
and they didn't want me to play for them
so I just had to do
best for me Chris I can't do that man go
go get a job and make some money
yourself dude it's a rough life being a
bad fan yeah
what was the last time the Bears won the
Super Bowl I shoot your hand into
YouTube and you put a hamster yeah
Brandon how it's tough do that hurt I
can't pay your phone bill Chris go get a
job and pay for your own bills man it's
capitalism dude you got to go out and
work for things as a child I loved it
man I just love working out I love
gaming so it's pretty easy for me to you
[Applause]
Oh baby give me it
[Applause]
are we gonna hit this street it's so
hard if I had a monitor I don't know
that was a nice clip let's go
what's up vidiq you know how do I got
six ya Redskins are tough to Gregor I'm
sorry if you men
[Applause]
[Applause]
nice Chelsea or a Jack Sparrow I don't
know Chris I think beggars would be the
suckfest though Benglis bengals jets
dolphins bears even I have a quarterback
is really yeah laughs coming nice
hope you having a great day thanks do I
hope you having a good day as well
critics of the greatest kapolei of all
time Brandon there's no debate most
successful player ever most off all like
yeah this mp5 is disgusting
oh my god oh this is mp5 Marco I think
it's the best submachine gun in Call of
Duty Rondo warfare we got a shotgun kid
over here we gotta be careful
friendly UAV on station boy I don't know
not get that kill games you enjoy' that
you don't really stream I don't know man
honestly my whole life is Call of Duty
you know it's where I spend all my time
doing so I just try to grind out cod and
to be the best cod player I could be you
know that would've been nice but he
shafted me right single final 13 any
games yeah and it went great iron
Heights coming what's good iron Heights
is that like another shell that bleach
report has are we allowed to talk about
that I don't when does it come and you
know we're not sure man we don't know
how I feel about crazy hours despite
dude I'm actually talking to her a lot
about like making thumbnails on YouTube
because he makes his own so he's gonna
teach me how to make thumbnails on
Photoshop Korea he's a really nice guy
he's one of the best like modern warfare
content creators I feel like right I
don't worry I think they're all over
here wait are they right here
shotgun nice I've loved this it feels
more like you've created another cluster
comments its number one thing extreme
them bro I mean I've never streamed on
YouTube before or let alone like sleet
reports YouTube channel before but I
think that's number one thing then no
matter what no matter how many viewers
you have where they have two viewers if
you have 200,000 viewers like it doesn't
make a difference you gotta make
everyone feel like they're involved yeah
good old Peter I'm gonna get me I'm
definitely gonna get into Photoshop so
that I can just make my own thumbnails
that's like my biggest thing with
content I just want to be able to make
my own nails y'all got this gun planed
you know this bumps this bums one for
Call of Duty majors man versus the
greatest players ever this bum this
bunker whip you're asking Call of Duty
that's for sure what's your leg workouts
routine I changed it every week Chris my
gym just got a brand new renovation
though I made these really nice squat
racks so I've been squatting heavy with
these squat racks recently I've been
really big into my squats
I don't want to push this guy enemy UAV
online nice and immediately gets killed
yeah says he planning sitting not today
no I might play some tournaments later
but I'm probably not gonna be there this
game make you miss the competitive
league now I mean the league's gonna
start in January so when it starts I'm
gonna be really excited to play it in
[Applause]
how much you bench my max benches 3:30
Big Boss I'm pretty sure when I spawn
here they all just spawned right back
over there Justin sucked in the face fat
I'm not really weird over they talk too
much what's up man theny hey that's so
hard to hit on these shots no thumb
sensor what do you think about this Cod
as opposed to other Cod sensor I think
this game has potential to be one of the
best Cod's but in this current state
it's definitely one of the worst cots
but I like the fact that has potential
and I think they're gonna change a lot
of good things about the game I don't
know how I'm even 16 and 19 right now
this is incredible I wonder if like
there's got to be other kids that play
casually that playing TVs as big as this
one - I wonder how they get used to it
you know what I mean
hello what's up optimist wherever you
stream i'll find you thanks Manny cool
fugitive yeah Jess my guy look good
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's awesome Cody what would be the
game to go through have caught in his
franchise are definitely 49 men hello
Darth Vader
[Applause]
[Applause]
santé Gregor you playing on a monitor
like seven years now playing on a big TV
is definitely a change oh that guy's not
that good a shot
really Zack yeah but like I said guys do
you have any questions to me at all just
let me know anything about battle
stations anything about calling do da da
franchise in that sports let me know
guys and also if you guys want to wait
hold on one second let me see exactly
what call it a new year said to me
because we have home games coming up
this year and I think there's like a
certain way you could get pre-opening
tickets all right so what I heard from
New York cuz I asked was is anything
they want me to say well I'm on the
stream we have home games coming into
New York in 2020 we can't say in the
days yet but if you guys are from the
New York area if you want to come out to
New York and like watch our games live
during the season you could sign up a 10
bucks calm /nya SL which is on my shirt
right here so n box calm slash and Raya
sale and you'll be able to know once the
tickets go on sale none of the tickets
been announced yet but it's gonna be
crazy
it's me a lot of fun we get two home
games for the season I think I'm pretty
sure we're allowed to say that but the
days haven't been announced yet so we
haven't even asked anything with it but
if you guys are interested in that let
me know and if you guys want any of the
merch to sub liners GG if you guys want
any sub ladders merch and then follow
sub liners on Twitter and Instagram I
think I think the guys over in New York
would be really happy if you guys could
support the team and do that find this
one point dude it's tough because
there's no like radar right now in in
pubs yeah Kisame what you what should
you eat before working and after so like
what I do I take my mirror placement
control before I work out or like a
muffin with control and then after
workout I love chicken and rice like if
you guys are regulars in my stream white
[ __ ] white rice and chicken just steamed
shaking with some Frank's Red Hot Sauce
is perfect men yeah the m4 needs a
slight McGregor I agree
I don't mind this Cod Julie and I think
it's growing on me I think after a
little bit more time it'll be a lot
better like once they make some
appropriate changes to the game they'll
be substantially better than what it is
right now
I don't care I'll get the mp7 a little
54
[Applause]
[Applause]
I didn't see him I don't think the
time-to-kill needs any adjustment to be
honest leave my favorite dog is probably
Drake favorite genre of music probably
like chill music like relaxing music
they usually listen to
oh you got whatever in the [ __ ]
window
[Applause]
these guys are so mad what this happen
[Applause]
shot
what have cities in I think this is the
HyperX headset I'm not too sure though
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
nice shot
yeah officers are definitely my favorite
headset we actually have like some
really cool custom ones for the New York
team
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god
put the tree do you miss playing
blackout sometimes I do dream out that
my battle stations probably say Quan or
maybe a LeBron I don't know I like say
quite a lot though I really like him
[Applause]
how are you pro player you honestly suck
yo Matthew hit me up that's one of you
want to do this go we're playing on a 55
inch screen so there's like severe leg
input just got a literally a spawn right
here there's like really bad leg input
when you play in a 55 inch screen this
guy's so mad it's a my grid CT Thank You
Gigi sake 1 definitely does not skip
blade a that's why they call him say
quads am I still gonna spawn right here
to this guy scream
[Applause]
[Applause]
that dude is funny yeah he's so annoyed
[Applause]
oh that's my leg on my big sheet yeah if
you plant a giant screen like the one
I'm playing on right now it's so hard to
like just move around in general
everything is just too late you know
what's up Victor Creed oh this is nice
we were scoring in two shots wonderful
[Applause]
it's battlestations just about
traditional sports players do you get to
talk to these women's voices - for the
pilot readjusted the Aaron Fox and Josh
Hart but obviously the show gets picked
up then we'll have like a lot more plans
we're doing a lot of cool stuff with a
bunch of other people - it is very
interesting regular it's very fast-paced
very engaging and very fun I promise
you're gonna love it
[Applause]
I might be better off to sit firing on
this monitor honestly instead of ambien
there's a huge difference with
millisecond response times Victor you
want to get something with a 1
millisecond picture anything more than
that it's gonna be substantially like
what I'm playing on it now it's got to
be like a 20 it's very substantial
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Gordon Hayward does have a good set up
he'll be great for the show as well I
like him
[Applause]
yeah you want me to wrap it at this game
okay guys my last game we're gonna try
to get this wind we're down by eight
kills but
[Applause]
[Applause]
dude yeah hottie percent Victor when you
get a game monitor get a 23 inch monitor
and get something with the one
millisecond or at most a two millisecond
response time like if you plan anything
else you're a severe disadvantage dude
like right now like I could probably be
having a completely different game if I
played on an actual monitor instead of a
TV which is five eighths
yeah I'm not mad or anything it's all
good though we just seem to find have
some fun but like in general if you're
trying to play competitively it's
impossible to play on anything that's
not at twenty three eighths you have to
get a good monitor I'm a brown on your
show I would love to have a brownish on
it the brown looks like food I that
would never happen right there I've had
a monitor that would never happen out
there but yeah the brown would be
incredible rate I mean he's gonna be a
tough guy to get man if anyone could
make it happen though it's bleacher
report what do you say you heard that
you said fast if anyone can get LeBron
James on battle station anyone it's
bleacher report so we're in good hands
guys
oh wow Toby get that tag boy
we lost by two that's tough dude thanks
for the share of course man
one girl my px4 smoked even if you
automatic okay Matthew you keep tripping
the Chairman I'll see you in the leaves
Oh
why are you a button because I'm on a
50-inch TV so guys we're gonna wrap it
there I want to say thank you if y'all
came out to the street hung out at me on
Bleacher Report's YouTube channel I'll
be live on my stream later for a rich
guy TV slash centrum where should I get
a Nuke new YouTube videos every day
obviously on youtube.com slash sensor
but battle stations Thursday 10 o'clock
Eastern in the morning on Bleacher
Report's twitter if you guys are
interested in watching it out first
episodes with the Aaron Fox I'm really
really curious to see the feedback on
and how you guys enjoy it but that's
we're gonna wrap it up for today guys I
hope you guys all enjoyed watching the
stream thank you guys so much
follow me on Twitter social media
everything is just at censor probably to
report obviously if you guys do already
I want to say thanks and yeah I think
that's we're gonna wrap it up guys thank
y'all for watching I hope you have a
great day it's penny more Doug since
tomorrow and I'm out peace out everybody